ON MY GRAVESTONE, I WOULD SAY,
SHE IS NEITHER AS GOOD OR AS BAD
AS PEOPLE SAY ABOUT HER.
>> Sean: HILLARY COULD NOT
STOP BY CHIMING IN ON TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT SAYING, AMERICA
DESERVES FREER AND FAIR
ELECTIONS.
THAT'S WHEN WE HAD LAST TIME,
THE ONE SHE LOST.
SEEMS LIKE EVERYDAY THERE IS
MORE BAD NEWS FOR SLEEPY,
CREEPY, CRAZY UNCLE JOE.
30330 THAT HAD BLEACHED HAIR ON
THE SUMMER.
IT REPORTED, UNDER BIDEN'S
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE CHARGE IN
1988 WAS KEPT UNDER WRAPS WHILE
HIS FATHER WAS ADVOCATING FOR
HARSHER DRUG LAWS UNDER THE U.S.
AND APPEARED FOR REACTION TO
THAT, AUTHOR OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BEST
SELLER, WHICH AREN'T.
ALSO THE AUTHOR OF RESISTANCE AT
ALL COSTS.
RICHARD, WE START WITH YOU.
OH, THAT IS A PROBLEM.
>> FOR HUNTER BIDEN, JOE BIDEN.
BOTH JOE BIDEN AND
HILLARY CLINTON HAVE MORE
BAGGAGE THAN AN AIRPORT TURMOIL.
HILLARY CLINTON'S SERIES IS
PROMOTING HERSELF.
WHICH IS WHAT HER BOOK IS ABOUT.
SHE DOESN'T PROMOTE BOOKS, SHE
PROMOTES HERSELF.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE SHE HAS
THIS PERSISTENT MLK LIKE A
DREAM, I HAVE A DREAM, I WILL
WALK ONTO THE STAGE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION NEXT
SUMMER AND BY ACCLAMATION, I
WILL BE THE NOMINEE BECAUSE THEY
ARE DEADLOCKED.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT SHE IS JUST
HAUNTED BY TOO MANY SCANDALS.
THE RAIN AND PAID TO PLAY
SCANDAL.
THE EMAIL SCANDAL.
AND OF COURSE, THE MOST RECENT.
SHE PAID FOR THE RUSSIA HOAX.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR MLK LIKE
DREAM, HILLARY.
>> Sean: KIMBERLEY STRASSEL,
YOU HAD A GREAT CATCH THIS WEEK.
IT HAD TO DO WITH GPS IS GLENN
SIMPSON BECAUSE WHAT THEY ARE
OFFICIALLY TELLING US IS
OPERATION HURRICANE INTEL,
WHICH McCARTHY SAYS HE CANNOT
HAVE IT UNTIL THE PRESIDENT
SIGNS OFF ON IT, THAT WOULD BE
OBAMA.
BUT THE CATCH IS A FUSION GPS
WAS ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
RUSSIA AND COLLUSION IN MAY.
MEANWHILE, THEY SAY IT DIDN'T
START UNTIL JULY 30TH OR 31ST.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
THIS IS VERY FISHY.
IF YOU GO THROUGH ALL THE
RELEVANT PLAYERS HERE, THE FBI
SAID WE WERE IN THINKING ABOUT
TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION UNTIL THE
END OF JULY.
YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT GLENN
SIMPSON'S SENATE TESTIMONY AND
HE SAYS THAT HE ONLY HIRED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IN MAY
BECAUSE HE WANTED HIM TO LOOK
INTO TRUMP'S BUSINESS DEALINGS.
THEN YOU GO AND YOU READ THE
REPORT AND HERE IS WHAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE TOLD THE IG.
HE SAID SIMPSON APPROACHED HIM
IN MAY SPECIFICALLY TO LOOK INTO
ANY TIES BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA AND WHETHER
OR NOT RUSSIA WAS TRYING TO GET
A SPECIFIC ELECTION OUTCOME.
WHERE DID GLENN SIMPSON GET THIS
NARRATIVE THIS EARLY IN THE
GAME?
>> Sean: I THINK THAT IS SUCH
A GREAT QUESTION.
WHAT DO YOU TAKE ON THIS?
>> HE GOT IT FROM AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
LIKELY THE INSTIGATOR OF THE
HOAX WHICH IS JOHN BRENNAN.
THE AMAZING PART IS IF YOU LOOK
AT THE TIME LINE, AND I PUT THIS
IN MY BOOK, WITHIN TWO WEEKS,
THE CHRISTOPHER STEELE COMES UPW
THE CHRISTOPHER STEELE COMES UPT
THE CHRISTOPHER STEELE COMES UPH
THE DOSSIER, AT LEAST OF THE
FIRST AND SECOND MEMOS.
IF YOU READ THOSE MEMOS, THAT IS
AN IMPOSSIBILITY.
UNLESS HE IS JUST FED A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE, AND OF COURSE THAT'S
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THE IG
REPORT.
THAT IT ALL LARGELY CAME FROM A
SUB SOURCE WHO IS FINALLY
CONFRONTED BY THE FBI AND HE
SAID, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THESE ARE ALL EXAGGERATIONS.
>> Sean: GIVE THE LAST WORD TO
KIMBERLY.
TAKE OUT THE SUB SOURCE THAT
SAYS, THAT WAS BARTOK.
ONE SUB SOURCE, YOU KNOW, WE
KNEW THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE
DIDN'T SAY IT BUT HE IS SAYING,
YOU ACTUALLY REALLY BELIEVED
THAT'S STORY IN MOSCOW?
>> HERE IS THE AMAZING THING, HE
GOES THROUGH THE REPORT, AND THE
FBI HAD ABOUT A MILLION RED
FLAGS THE SECOND THIS REPORT
CAME IN, YET THEY DIDN'T BOTHER
TO FIND THE SOURCE AND TALK TO
HIM UNTIL JANUARY 2017.
THEY COULD'VE SAVED THE COUNTRY
SO MUCH GRIEF IF THEY HAD DONE
BASIC DUE DILIGENCE ON THIS GUY
AND HIS REPORTING AND SPARED US